えっとね、あの幼児から、ま、入用児から
幼児、その辺まで見とる。そうすると
入用児の時は女の方が断然強いよね。男は
ダメだ。それがあるから男は強くなら
なくっちゃうと思うんだね。しばらく用事
になってくると男の方が強くなってくるん
だ。で、それを見取ると女の子は女の子
らしくなるわな。だから男の世界を作って
やる。男の世界を作ってやるとそこにいる
女の子が女らしくなるんや。それを今日本
見て女の世界を必死だって作っとるじゃん
。あのバカマスコミね。あいつは自分たち
の商売のためだ。マスコミのお客さんは女
やもんね。だから女の機嫌を取るような
ことばっかりやっとるんよ。その当然の
結果として男を否定する。男はダメだと
いう風に否定する。その中で暮らしとる
子供はどうなる?否定されっぱなしやから
な。男はダメだと思っちまう。自分が大人
になって子供ができてその子供を育てる時
にやっぱり同じように育っちまうわな。男
はダめ。女は優れているということで子供
は不安になる。男の仕事は愛という言葉に
表されるけども愛だ愛だって叫ぶやに限っ
て愛とは何か知らんよね。何度も都合が
悪くなると愛だからつってごまかして
しまう
。愛の定義をせずに愛こそ全てと言って
言われた方はなんかようわからん。あ、
おそらくこれが愛だろうと思われるような
ことをそれが最高なんだ。全てなんだと
本人たちが思い込んじまって女にとっては
非常に都合が良かったんだ。子供は
甘やかしてもええんよね。愛なんだから。
だけど子供を甘やかすのは愛かな。あれは
ね、女にとっては愛かもしれんだけど、男
にとっては愛じゃないよ。子供を甘やかす
のか。それがわからんとね。そこで
お父さんが出てくるんじゃ。で、お父さん
の愛で子供を座っていうね、こういうね、
考えとこら。お父さんがいて、お母さんが
いて、まだ小さい子供が1人いて、その子
がま、やんちゃなりわがままなり、
わがままに育っちまって言うこと聞か
生意きなことばっかり言う。お父さんが
止まりかねてペーンって引っちまうと子供
がわーっと泣く。泣いたらお母さんが慌て
て飛んできてその子供取っ
てかわいそうかわいそう。お父さんに文句
言うね。これはお父さんは本能的に子供の
将来を心配したんだ。こんなことじゃ将来
ダメになるだろう。だから直してやろうと
して引っぱいたいんだね。これ将来を守る
。その子の将来を自分でちゃんと守らせる
。守る。これが愛だ。で、お母さんは今の
心配したんや。だから、今に対する、今を
守る、今に対する愛。これがお母さんな、
女なん。だから教育のような将来に対する
目的を持っとるもの、戦略的目的を持っ
とるものは男がやらなくっちゃ。女の本能
でやっちまったら今っだから将来ダメに
なっちまうよ。か男の本能であれば将来の
ためにやるんだから将来が良くなで教育の
ように将来のためにやっとる。これは男の
仕事やね。だけど1番肝心な幼稚園、保育
園小学校女の理論でやっとるよね。女の
先生ばっかりやないか
。うちでやってた、ま、落ちこぼれ、
投拒否飛行引きこもり。そういう家庭をま
、何千人か見てきたわけやね。で、そこの
家庭に完全に共通があるんや。相対的に
不正が弱い。これはお父さんが本当に精神
的に弱い人なのか、お母さんが強すぎるの
か、家電やね。それか家庭だ。みんなその
どれかに当てはまったよ。なぜそんなこと
になるかと言うと、お父さんは男、男の
仕事として家庭を守るというのがあるや
ないか。もし飯が食えんようになったら
いかんもんで、ちゃんと金を持ってきて
やる。これも家庭を守ることやんね。で、
それよりもよそからわけのわからんやが
飛び込んできて家族殺すぞって言ったら
お父さんが守ってやるからお父さんは強く
ないといかん。今そんなことはあんまり
考えれんけど昔は実際にそういうことが
しょっち起こったんよね。よその家庭を
乗っとるというはぐれ狼みたいな男がおっ
てね。そういうことをやったわけだから
安定して暮らすには安心して暮らすには
お父さんが強いという必要がある。で、
その本能は今でも残っとるもんで残念
ながらね。だから自分の時のお父さんがま
、精神的にだよ弱いと子供は不安になって
くるんや。暗証教あの法則によって進歩し
ないんよ。不安定では。で、その不安が
募って学校行けんようになる。投やね。
あるいは社会からはみ出す飛行やね。飛行
っていうのが強いように見えるけど飛行
っていうのは弱いんよね。不良は強いんだ
。だから飛行と不良が違うもんだという
ことがよう分からんといかんよね
。だから男はまず精神的にできたら肉体的
にも強くなろうや。そう男の役目は果たせ
ん。1番大事な役目だ。家族を守る。これ
が家族に対する愛やないか。愛というのは
守るということ。あんなベタベタしたのは
守ったことにならんやろから母親の愛と
いうのはその子供の今を守ろうとするもん
でどうしてもベタベタになるわね。だけど
あれはおかしいんや。子供がやるべきこと
を代わりにやっちまったりして子供が心ん
やろ今を問題にするからそういうことに
なるんや。男やったら将来を問題にする
からおも自分でやれということになるんや
ね。そこ間違えんようにね。
母親目線だとどういうことをすればいいとかどういう姿勢で子育てに望むといいとかってありますか?あ、いわゆる母性本の動物見とっても分かる。まあ
100%
守ったるということやね。して人間なんだから何もかも守ってやろうとすんのはしょうがない。それでええんだ。ただし
歳だにしとこうよ。それから先は父親の意見の子供を育てよう。
そっから独立していかんといかんのやから
時間かかるんやからね。何でも自分で
やらして進歩させる。進歩には何も起こら
んから。だからできたら3歳までに進歩の
能力をつけとこうよ。けどお母さんは
なかなかそれができんからな。お父さんに
やらしたりだけだけど今お父さんもこれが
できんよね。お母さんよりもっと甘くなっ
ちまったりしてね。
女性の役割としては本能のままに子供を愛してで一定の年齢になったらちゃんと父親が主導で子育てをしていくっていう状態にちゃんとタッチができんといかんな。それができんじゃん。それはね、うちはその極端にひどいやつが来るからね。もう母親がもう
100%
その子供を抱え込んじまってなと子供は母親からはまれるのが怖くてしょうがない。
小学校の6年生でな、こうやって母親に
ずっと抱きついとるわ。うちにやってくる
。うちにやってきて父親が連れてくるんだ
。だけど子供だけ連れてくれええんだけど
母親がくっついてきちまう何にもできんよ
。着替えろ言ったって嫌っつってもうそれ
でおしまいやで着替えさせようとすると
母親が邪魔するわけな。で、最後はね訴え
るって言い出すわ。子供に対する暴力を
振っとるというだけやな。嫌がっとるや
ないかけどそんなものは母親がそうしたん
やけどね。なかなかそうはもう私は精一杯
子供を愛してという言い出すからね。結局
一生ダメになっちゃう。その子ね喋らん
やったよ。看目時や。喋る必要ないねんよ
。自分の要求は全部母親が察知してやって
くれるもんでさ。から子供でも口の遅い
のっていうのはそういう場面が多いやろ。
母親があまりにもパッと殺チするもんで
から長女の場合よりも事女の方があれ
じゃん。長女で大体母親が分かるわけだ。
あ、今何したい?今何したい?で、事女の
場合はもう何にも言わんでもりを示さんで
もパッとやっちまっね。すと喋る必要
なくなってくるわけね。喋らんだよね。
そういうこれが母の愛の場合が多いやろ。
こう無限の愛というのかな。無限の
甘やかしやね。結局本人を認めてないと
いうことや。自分でやらえん。そいつは
もう本人私がやってあげる言ってやっ
ちまうわけだからね。
[音楽]